what up it's your girl sally aka
salamander aka sally monaco on all
socials you should follow me if you've
been following me on this journey of
watching all the marvel movies phases
one through four this is the finale of
phase one okay we are watching the
avengers
i'm excited okay we're almost done with
phase one that rhymed call me
dr seuss that didn't rhyme if you like
this video oh while you're watching it
might make you laugh if you like looking
at me if you like my spiderman in the
back please give this video a like it
really does help the algorithm it helps
boost the channel also hit that
notification bell if you want to know
when my next video is going to be up if
you would like to watch my full reaction
you could sit down use your own copy
obviously you can head over to their
patreon
www.who says that that's last century
why did i say
duh okay it's patreon.com the real
rejects if you want to watch that and
greg or john have a bunch of other fun
stuff on there so go check it out for
them too lastly i'd like to give an epic
shout out to prepper because you edited
together the highlights for this video
let's hope it doesn't get copyrighted
let the finale of phase one
begin out
[Music]
the tesseract is not only active she's
behaving i assume you pull the plug
she's an energy source we turn off the
power she turns it back on
if she reaches peak level we're prepared
for this doctor so the tesseract's a
girl of course she's gonna take over the
world and dangerous
yeah
oh boy sir
please put down the spear
what made you think he would listen
ew they put a cracking
sound effect when he had a spine on the
wall yeah why
what the heck maybe two minutes before
this goes critical broken
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh jeez
nice
oh
my god
what
[Music]
ah oh my god
no
um
that
he just jumped out of a helicopter
what
tesseract is with a hostile force
i have men down
a lot of men still under how is she not
having a panic attack
you're in a cave
trapped as of right now
we are at war
what do we do
avengers assemble
your mantle
adjust her tmj like
i get that done at the
chiropractor put the woman on the phone
or i will blow up the block before you
can make the lobby
we need you to come in are you kidding
i'm working this takes precedence i'm in
the middle of an interrogation this
[ __ ] is giving me everything
i don't
give everything
let me put you on hold
okay
[Music]
oh my god
nice
you get the big guy
okay so this is the mark ruffalo
hulk
you know for a man who's supposed to be
avoiding stress you picked a hell of a
place to settle
i assume the whole place is surrounded
just you and me
and your actress buddy
she got me
it emits a gamma signature that's too
weak for us to trace
there's no one that knows gamma
radiation like you do
talk to fury he needs you on this he
needs me in the cage no one's going to
put you on stop lying to me
what the [ __ ]
i'm really here
to chill
stand down
we're good here
just you and me
you know that was a lie come on you're
saying that this
asgard is declaring war on our planet
not asgard loki
his brother our intelligence says thor
is not a hostile they look like those
talking heads in the haunted mansion
that sing
you won't be alone
oh my god
this guy's still alive
he needs therapy for sure for sure
that works too
i wish we could actually use suits like
that that looks so cool
i'm in dc tomorrow i'm working on the
zoning for the next three buildings
pepper you're killing me the moment
remember
enjoy the moment and get in here and i
will
oh
sir agent colson of shield is on the
line i'm not in
i'm actually out
is he wearing air pods before air broads
were a thing
you know i thought we were having a
moment i was having 12 percent of the
moment
this is serious phil's pretty shaken how
would you know this why is he phil what
so this dr banner was trying to
replicate the serum they used on me
a lot of people were
you were the world's first superhero oh
that's what the serum was
in the incredible hulk i didn't know
that
he's not that thing though guys like a
stephen hawking
he's like a
smart person
poor guy
it's an honor to meet you
officially
i sort of met you i mean i watched you
while you were sleeping
edward khalid i was present while you
were unconscious was he in love with
captain america did he ask you to sign
his captain america trading cards yet
trading cards that's cute
is this a submarine
really
they want me in a submerged pressurized
metal container
oh that's scary mm-hmm
never mind
that's so
cool we're at level sir
good
let's vanish
that's so cool
oh no
uh
[Music]
oh
i said
imagine someone's like i'm the old man
i'm gonna shut up now in the end
you will always kneel
not to men like you there are no men
like me
are always men like you
oh i got chills
and they're in germany too
yes
the soldier
why do you say it like that run out of
time
i'm not the one who's out of time
[Music]
sold
ah
yeah
that's not my name
damn
make a move reindeer games
what's your thing pilates
what
it's like calisthenics you might have
missed a couple things you know
doing time is a capsicle
capsicle
bro
what's the matter
scared of a little lightning
i'm not overly fond of what follows
where's your horse
there's a fly
i look like they're on a kiss the guys
are friendly doesn't matter if he frees
loki or kills him the tesseract's lost
stark we need a plan of attack i have a
plan
attack the humans slaughter each other
in droves while you idly fret
i mean to rule them that's why should i
not think yourself above them
oh yes
oh everyone in the supreme court
i don't have it
you need the cube to bring me home but
i've sent it off i know not where
you listen well brother
i'm listening
geez
capacity
how about that
[Music]
what did that tree do to you
hey
that's enough you want me to put the
hammer down
[Music]
[Music]
he really grows on you doesn't he
i want to know why loki let us take him
he's not leading an army from here i
don't think we should be focusing on
loki that guy's brain is a bag full of
cats he could smell crazy on him
loki is beyond reason but he is of
asgard and he's my brother he killed 80
people in two days
he's adopted
no hard feelings point break you gotta
mean swing
plea break
breath tough
that man is playing galaga
thought we wouldn't notice
and i'd like to know how loki used it to
turn two of the sharpest men i know into
his personal flying monkeys monkeys
do not understand i do
i understood that reference i have seen
that that jiff
i won't touch barton not until i make
him kill you
slowly
you brought the monster
loki means to unleash the hulk banner in
the lab
he got played
big man in a suit of armor take that off
what are you
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist
you're not the guy to make the sacrifice
play
to lay down on a wire or let the other
guy crawl over you i think i would just
cut the wire you're a laboratory
experiment rogers everything special
about you came out of a bottle
damn
shots fired
what
i got long
i didn't see an end so i put a bullet in
my mouth and the other guy spit it out
what
oh
no
ah
on my life i will get you out of this
you will walk away and
never no
[Music]
no
everyone's like bye
oh
it'll slow the rotors down long enough
for me to get out stand by it wait for
my word
oh no i would not have done that mm-hmm
bro
target engaged
dude
oh my gosh
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
are you ever not going to fall for that
oh my god
move away please
you like this
we started working on the prototype
after you sent the destroyer even i
don't know what it does
want to find out
no
what the f
what an [ __ ]
oh oh my god
he's gonna feel that when he wakes up
out of that chance oh my god
[Music]
i don't know how that worked
but it worked
where is my disadvantage
you lack conviction
i don't think
yes
[Applause]
so that's what it does
[Music]
i hope he gets to be healed even though
i think that's impossible
[Music]
sorry boss
the god rabbited
just stay awake
eyes on me
this was never gonna work
they didn't have something
to
[Music]
i guess he never did get you to sign
them
stop
you saw the whole thing right through
the ceiling
bacon green and buck ass nude
[Music]
just don't
son
he wants to show us something a new
universe
okay
oh
please tell me you're going to appeal to
my humanity
uh actually i'm planning to threaten you
you should have left your armor on for
that seen a bit of mileage and you've
got the uh
little stick of destiny close stick of
destiny
maybe your army comes and maybe it's too
much rust but it's all on you
because if we can't protect the earth
you can be damn well sure we'll avenge
it
oh i like that lion you will all fall
before me
oh my god
he could have burned those people
i wonder how long they were just sitting
there waiting
that was a cool shot
what
[Music]
why do you all keep believing him
[Music]
oh
okay good timing why the hell should i
take orders from you
i
ah
my god
dr banner now might be a really good
time for you to get angry
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry
oh
what is that
[Music]
oh put your mask back on
yes look at all of them
[Music]
send the rest
what
oh my gosh
loki you're gonna give me a headache
you and me we stay here on the ground
keep the fighting here
and hulk
smash
ah
oh my god
whoa
wow
[Applause]
where is loki
sure about this
yeah
it's gonna be fun
[Music]
that's bold she doesn't really have any
like super strength or anything like
that
[Applause]
oh my god
i recognize the council has made a
decision but given that it's a
stupid-ass decision
[Music]
that's so dangerous imagine he had shot
that down without knowing she was on it
what
[Applause]
[Music]
you are all of you beneath me
i am a god you dull creature
and i will not
oh man that was the best part
we hear the tale of jonah i wouldn't
consider him a role model
[Music]
[Music]
they just go through glass so easily my
goodness
oh man
i can shut the portal down do it no wait
start these things are still coming i
got a nuke coming in it's going to blow
in less than a minute i know just where
to put it
[Music]
good night
[Music]
close it
come through
kind of a guy
he's not slowing down can you pass out
[Music]
uh
just happened
please tell me nobody kissed me
it's just not coming tomorrow let's just
take a date
you ever tried shwarma
there's a shawarma joint about two
blocks from here i don't know what it is
but i want to try it
we're not finished yet
and then swarm after
he's nothing's worse than being hungry
not being able to eat
if it's all the same to you
i'll have that drink now
superheroes
spiderman
nice touch
hey
and i'm not gonna mess this up i'm gonna
watch
the end credit scene so let's just skip
to it
uh
[Laughter]
oh i love it
i thought i did everything right
this is my youtube apology video listen
i was impatient the movie ended i said
listen sally you cannot skip that
post-credits scene so i fast forwarded
out realizing there was a mid credit
scene i am a mess
and you don't have to forgive me it's
unforgivable honestly cancelled so
i'm going to be watching the mid credit
scene in my apologetic
makeup classic light blue shirt i think
i skipped to the right part
is to court
death
is that
that thanos dude i see everywhere
he's got an ugly chin i've seen him in
the promotional stuff for end game
was the other one infinity war sorry
infinity war that one for sure okay
he doesn't like humans he's shocked he's
like i thought they were weak
and they're not i don't think i'm gonna
change that sorry loki step aside you
got another villain
to compete with
okay that was worth it
he had pretty eyes it matches the lights
i don't know if i should be
complimenting him i don't think so
i don't think so
sorry i apologize forgive me subscribe
to my channel i'm putting out a new
video soon just kidding don't plug it
it's fine
i don't deserve it
well guys that
was the avengers
and a few stray flies around my room
that would not stop hitting me in the
face first of all
it was a long movie and i knew that
going into it but i wasn't bored at all
it really kept my attention the pacing
was perfect this movie was solid
now i get why people
went crazy over this movie when it first
came out because this was the first
movie of its kind where you're having a
bunch of different
characters and then
one big movie where all of their lives
intertwine into one big action-packed
thriller this was
so well done i was so entertained all
throughout it usually with action movies
i tend to space out or get really bored
but again the piecing of this was
honestly perfect i loved the scene where
they were all arguing and getting to see
each character and each superhero and
their own personalities and what they've
gone through because we've seen them go
through it
just go at it with each other was
chef's kiss i just loved seeing that
scene it was perfect i'm sure the
writers had a lot of fun with that and i
wonder how many other variations of that
scene that there were because i'm sure
there were probably many different
variations or drafts i'm curious to see
if there are any deleted scenes or
alternate scenes with that i
stand by this statement if you have a
great villain you're gonna have a great
movie it makes the heroes look even
better when the villain is definitely a
villain that you can actually i wouldn't
say sympathize with but there was
weirdly something very likable about
loki and now i understand why i see so
much merch with loki on it it's kind of
charming and it's not something that is
used that often with villains but when
it is done well it's done
well it made the whole movie way more
interesting because it's like oh it's i
don't know with a lot of movies i get
frustrated it's like oh it's a villain
just doing villain things yes he has the
same motives of just like i want to
control everything and i don't care if i
kill people in the process but there's
something about him that's so
manipulative and so charming and cunning
that you're kind of just always
wondering like what he's gonna do next
he was just a oddly very likable villain
so i think that made this movie ten
times better than it would have been if
it would have just been a very generic
overdone you know type villain hats off
to tom hiddleston for playing this
character he did such a good job they
all did such a good job all of the
comedic moments in this movie hit it for
me i loved how funny this movie was when
you're least expecting it i think my
favorite was the galaga
and the end credits scene like that's
just something you think about i thought
about it i was like do they ever get to
like go to the bathroom or just like eat
and like i don't know that was so
humanizing to see them all just sitting
down eating food that was perfect
obviously i already knew there was an
iron man 3 so his little moment where
you feel like he might be dead i was
like obviously like well he's not but
they played that off perfectly with the
comedy in that scene it's really great
to see
black widow natasha being such a badass
character i think it was eluded in iron
man that she was kind of they kind of
wrote her
i didn't really like some of what was
that iron man 2
where they kind of just made her a sex
symbol so it was really nice in this
movie to see her actually
i don't know be a very multi-dimensional
character i know there's a black widow
movie
it's one of the newer ones i didn't see
it uh so i'm really excited to see that
later on in phase
four is it phase four that that's i
don't know i mean a great action movie
for me is a movie where you're kind of
wondering how are they gonna get out of
this so every time something happens
you're like how are they going to fix
this what are they going to do and i
kept having those thoughts during this
movie so that really i think was also
the main reason why i kept my attention
was because there were a lot of things
that i just couldn't predict and i
thought it was very surprising in many
parts
really upset that coulson died i'm
i'm really mad about that i also
in comparison to the incredible movie i
think in that movie i was really
confused like oh i thought he was
supposed to you know kind of black out
and not remember
certain things or people like he was
definitely way too
soft in that movie this movie he was
badass
he definitely
obviously the first scene that he
changes didn't remember
natasha which was terrifying for her and
so i'm just really glad he kind of got a
glow up in this movie and i love
microflow he makes him so likable that
was really exciting to see captain
america and
iron man remind me of like bickering
brothers which i think is great because
they like hate each other but also love
each other and you can tell it's really
cute i don't really know
where
this is gonna go like i don't know i
know there's more avengers movies but
this was wrapped up so well i'm like i
don't know how they would top this movie
to be honest with
a more
i don't know cunning villain or or
anything because again it's really hard
to do movies like this
and not lose the attention of the
audience so yeah i'm really curious to
see what the other avengers movies are
about this one's solid absolutely solid
solid film 10 out of 10 disney did a
great job with assembling all of them
so
that's my take on the avengers guys
again if you like my reaction please
give it a like and then hit that
subscribe button because there are
plenty of other videos that greg and
john have on the channel not just me if
this is your first time watching this
was such a pleasure to watch with you
guys i'm so excited and
i just hit the table i'm so excited i
just i hit the table
peace